[Musique]
chez toi un truc qu'il en jette
c'est sûr que tu arriveras joue du piano
avec ça
[Musique]
c'est me tue j'entendais la mélodie dans
ma tête tout est là je voulais tout le
noter il fallait que ça sorte
[Musique]
chan
c'est quoi ton nom déjà je m'appelle
dragué reginald dwight reginald c'est le
prénom de mon grand père et comment est
ce qu'un petit gros sorti de nulle part
peut devenir une star il faut tuer
l'homme que tu devais être pour devenir
l'homme que tu as toujours voulu écrire
je crois que je vais changer de nom et
m'appeler elton mais c'est mon nom je
sais tu pourrais être une star en
amérique si tu voulais il faut que tu
sors du lot chez toi un truc qui en
jette
c'est sûr que tu arriveras joue du piano
avec ça
[Musique]
montrent leur qui tu es
ebit juste ben tu es avec la drogue
quel effet ça fait des trous ça ça va
pas durer
alors profitons-en tant qu'on peut si
notre histoire s'ébruite tout s'arrêtera
j'espère que tu te rends compte que tu
choisi d'être seul pour toujours tu
voudrais pas te contenter de chanter
sans cesse accoutrement ridicule 1 les
gens ne paient pas pour voir ready
dwight il mais pour voir elton john
désolé je sais
tu te soucies au moins la pression que
je suis pas vraiment je toucherai
toujours mais 20 % longtemps après que
tu te sois foutu en l'air
[Musique]
peut-être que j'aurais dû être plus
banal
tu n'as jamais été malade
quel petit garçon timide tu éclaires
regarde toi maintenant